ben wyatt hello uh hi leslie good to see
you
wow you're really burning up can i get
some money for
the cab that i took over here please
sure how much i'm not sure
i looked at the meter and it had
egyptian hieroglyphics on it
do you know the exchange rate so should
we do this
oh boy hold on be careful what
the floor on the wall just switched
okay walk very carefully
you know i find it a little insulting
that you don't trust me to handle this
it's not i don't trust you okay it's
just this
harvest festival is my project it's my
career on the line
and i just need to make sure that i've
done everything i can to make it work
okay it's showtime
okay good evening everyone i'm leslie
monster and this
is nightline thank you so much for
carrying that
i will buy you guys dinner later liz we
both have girlfriends
this is it 4d tracy i am going to need
you to take a picture
you just push the little button on top
thanks a lot i never operated a camera
before
i'm serious that was very helpful
make sure you get the hug
oh hi i brought these presents as part
of the letters to sansa program
what just happened what's the past tense
for scam is this grumped
this lemon i think you just got scrumped
if you win he's all yours and if i win i
bring him back to the farm for good
wait what that wasn't the deal pour it
i'm thirsty pour me one too then let me
in here
i'm gonna join you and if i win
ron stays here with us leslie no don't
drink that
we use it to burn warts off of the mules
poison oh
i made a mistake i made a mistake
had not of this watered down baby
formula
not even close not even clothes
marvin clones
going close leslie you don't have to do
this
go to bed jimmy
i can't feel my face my face is numb
oh what's the special occasion weekday
wow so this is normal this is like your
version of sweatpants and pop-tarts
not two shabs short for shabby hilarious
this could be your life too liz just
short the housing market
or write a cookbook specifically for
mixed race children or marry a rich old
dude who dies
clive i want to say or have mild lupus
and great
insurance so here is the plan for today
start with facials and massages
private shopping at bergdorf swing by
the dermatologist
for a tune-up dinner at jewelbacho then
a nightcap back here
oh wow that is a plan but uh i don't
think i should go
oh liz is still stressed about her old
job oh
it's just it's friday and at my job that
is our biggest
day i don't think i'd be good company
but thank you for inviting me i'll have
one drink here
have two but then i really should go
home because i know i'm still in work
mode i'm not really in
spa shopping mode i wouldn't be able to
enjoy myself
and i don't want to crash your day
together and ruin it we're always
together
a cocktail it's just so stressful
thinking about my employees trying to
do everything without me those look
great on you then i'm buying them
i guess i'm just one of those people
that needs work you know i thrive there
and it's gone just like that just like
that thank you dr binderman
isn't he amazing my point is you are so
sweet to include me believe me i'm
jealous but
today is just not the day so you know
i'll hang out with you guys for a little
bit
and i'll have my one drink and what time
is it almost midnight
if we're gonna get up in time for our
mani pedis we really should turn in
ah i hate it here this place is evil
i think these are the only two films
that say sweetums on the label yeah well
let's take them both we might find
something interesting
here just stick them under my shirt just
walk out they have
sensors just check them out it's free
hi marcy leslie are they finally
teaching you parks people how to read
oh i guess not it's a movie you're
pretty cocky for someone whose job is
obsolete because of the internet
[Laughter]
let's see hmm you seem to have a 40
late fee on a book called mysteries of
the female orgasm
no i don't yeah you do and grab the
movie
go go go go
pumpkin jockey
i want you all to know how happy i am
right now being here with you people has
helped me more than you can know to us
oh man look at us it's just like we're
back in high school right
you know it was always my favorite thing
seven minutes in heaven
you always got the bottle to land on me
you think you still have the touch
oh yeah come on
just to be clear we're not making out
that would be social suicide
ugh like i even want to be here in this
closet at this reunion it's a nightmare
the nightmare for whom lemon
if these jagweeds don't want to get to
know the nice new me then screw them and
they're
rapidly yellowing teeth wow lemon you
really haven't changed have you excuse
me what happened when i told you guys
that screwed me over for the ceo job did
you offer your help as a friend or did
you make some joke about me being
impotent
geez that was like eight hours ago i was
just i don't know
cutting the tension or as always were
you hiding behind your sense of humor
instead of engaging in a real way
really i'm the one that's hiding larry
braverman there it is
right there when you feel threatened you
attack that's why you're almost 40 and
you're still alone
at least i'm not 50 alone and sitting on
2 000 business cards for a job i'm never
gonna get
what did you say yeah your bags were
delivered to my room by accident
look what i found you went to a printer
didn't you
you picked out a font you paid extra for
a rush order
it was your happy little secret
[Music]
whoa what are you doing why is she
so mean
what'd you do to braverman she's awful
she's the gay one
look we are going to be here for 10
hours we can either talk about our
issues and work through our problems or
we can just sit here doing nothing
i choose sit here come on ron why don't
we just sit here
ron sit here
i bet i can make you talk i'll take that
bet
at any odds for any amount of money over
any length of time stretching from now
into infinity
talk to me talk to me talk to me
one word and this is over i think wood
is stupid so is everybody else
you guys ron loves plastic last chance
ron
you want to talk huh
jackpot you know what this is ron this
is a mix i made for the summer parks
barbecue 2007.
i asked everyone in the parks department
to choose one song
you chose buddy by willie nelson
a fact i remember because my mind is a
steel trap of friendship nuggets
but i am not going to play your choice
i'm gonna play jerry's choice
[Music]
oh that's right and i'm gonna sing along
and i'm gonna maintain eye contact the
whole time
and guess what i don't know the words
harry truman was the guy
america red china all the countries
other people everyone is fun
joe montagna emiquel and i have to buy
new toaster this is awesome you're so
stupid jumping up and down
[Music]
oh i got it on repeat come on you want
to hear it again or do you want to talk
no okay well thank you for explaining
that i always wanted to know how a
universal remote works
well that's how it does
would you excuse me just one second i'll
be right back
oh geez stew what was i thinking
[Music]
i think your brownies are burning you
want me to take them out oh yes please
um but whatever
you do don't open that kitchen window
no no too soon
you